foreign
hello and welcome to the view from
22. now the week before last uh on our
Flagship show the week in 60 minutes we
had the qriket commentator Henry blovelt
on talking about the first ashes test
and viewers seem to like it a lot we had
a lot of uh positive feedback and so we
thought we'd bring him back for a view
from 22 to talk about the second ashes
test match which finished yesterday is
sadly for for Englishmen in another
defeat um for in the Lords the
Australians won by a slightly more
comfortable uh margin than they did
before but it was nonetheless a
thrilling test match it was however a
controversial test match and today Rishi
sunak the Prime Minister has got
involved by saying that he didn't like
the dismissal of Johnny bairstow in the
second Innings which was a stumping a
controversial stumping
um and he thinks he would rather if he
he would not have liked to have won in a
way the Australians one uh Henry we
better start with that because that's
the big talking point of the day what
did you think of the dismissal and what
do you think of Rishi sunak getting
involved
um I I think it probably is it I see
what he's trying to say but I think that
he's got to realize that we live in a
changing world
if you it's no good I think no this in
2023 being a squeamish about this as we
would have been uh years and years ago
when an Ashley's match comes down from
pressurized finish he saw things like
this called actually and will actually
happen the Australians defense will be
was in within the letter law and as such
one's got to say it is over and it just
says out I think
um I Bell still is a quite an experience
as Gregory he knows what pressure is and
with England Building up towards a
sensational Victory the pressure out
there was enormous these things are
likely to happen and he was a bit clumsy
and I think when he thinks about it
he'll realize that so I know the gut
reaction will produce
in the MCC million and I would guess I
know but that's
um in fact I I dare say red face is
caused by the Sun and perhaps a modicum
of a glass or to who knows
and people do feel all down to the
collar and I'm glad the MCC has taken an
action well the three people have been
suspended uh well temp at any rate with
immediate effects are these little
Richard thing to happen and I think
one's got to realize so that this sort
of thing doesn't happen in cricket and
after all
um England it was with Douglas Johnny
took body line to Australia in 1992-33
and unfortunately these little things do
happen there is the rule about running
out of batsman at the non-strikers end
it used to be that you give him one
warning and I think that is now gone
because you don't want to take Wicked
like this on a regular basis but when
the pressure gets really tight these
sort of things are going to happen and I
I think you once got to understand this
we live in a world which is changing
changing fast it's becoming a more
violent more difficult world than it was
um 30 years ago when I dare say most of
those members have got very angry at
Lords uh learned that Cricket I don't
think that sort of thing would have
happened then it probably wouldn't even
have after the series but we it's a
different age now and I think Cricket
always like it is more uh walked hand in
Step so to speak with Society at that
time it reflects that
and I think I think I mean you look
around the the chaos all around us
um I I I somehow can't get as white as
what job as as a lot of people do over
this I know it's unfortunate I know
Stokes played one of the great Innings
of ingredients history and of course
would have been enormously fitting had
he taken into a sensational Victory uh
he didn't investor will be I I think
Bowser will be kicking himself a bit for
doing what he did and I just feel that
bear up I think the Australians actually
outplayed Us in that match again and I'm
I'm obviously I'm sad that I do nothing
of the Azure series but I think
well the Aussies are accusing us of of
pomi palm hypocrisy uh do you think we
do have to accept that we are a little
bit hypocritical when it comes to these
things
well yes I mean I think we are as Isaiah
we um borderline 32 degrees we we really
I mean that was very much against the
spirit of the game wasn't it that was
Daddy I invented part around Reddit to
get rid of Don Bradman and and it was it
was a messy business but I think when I
get tight personal Works in baliwares
and I think we live in a society now
where it is easier or laws right to the
very end which they did yeah and get it
and I mean the fact is it was out I mean
it would be a great video of course it
was happening again but with it is
within the framework of the rules and
you may say that the Lord should be
tightened so that these situations
as we you know living in age when they
make might be being used like this
um but I mean I think it was uh England
in fact had the winning of that Desmond
when they won the toss they wasted that
on the first day they had the winning a
bit clearly on the second day when they
were 181 and Nathan Lauren was out for
the series I don't know you could see
that with where he was in a heap on the
field and yet they um absolutely throw
it away then they they the salt bridge
building they could hold it and were all
go down there you know a fine leg and
wherever and I thought it was
desperately wasteful batting and that my
wife has ball players say
um if we can't win we'll lose we mustn't
draw that is nonsense still an active
series a draw can particular energy is a
very honorable result it can be known
resulted in this series and um I I mean
I agree long drawn Outdoors I'm
desperate but occasionally draws
well played you've done Jolly well to
get that and I think that we've got to
remember this and I do think what this
series is showing us so far that
basketball has got a number of rough
edges we've just simply got sandpapered
down and we can't go and say in
basketball or nothing because I mean the
religious public are enjoying it
certainly but if you've gone playing
Australia and losing my two wickets
losing my 40 odd runs
um and they aren't going to enjoy it
forever because Victory becomes quite
important and I think this is something
that McAllen said
well
um basketball is meant to be
entertainment put a high priority on
entertainment
um but there was that uh spell of
bowling in the Australian uh second
Innings I think it was
um where we bowled nothing but short
stuff was it 98 percent
of our deliveries were short and that's
not quite Bodyline I know that's
different but it's it was negative
Cricket in a way wasn't it and it wasn't
very entertaining to watch
Bodyline what made 29 difference in the
field
Those infielders Behind the weed as you
wanted in those days and that's what
made it so impossible the Australians
getting away with it you went two men
back behind Square in the deep and you
add as many as three men at five square
short legs and we're allowed to do that
and he did make it extremely
um difficult
um I don't know I just feel that uh um I
mean if short pitch fast bowling like
that is the answer to Bas ball it's
quite it's quite a museum ironically
back because
um basketball may be one of the exciting
the antidote to it is as boring as hell
yeah because watching bounces build
endlessly is is a great big yawn no one
wants to see that I mean he really
there's that section when England were
building Australia and indeed with
Australia uh well it wasn't as bad
boring when Australia but it didn't
because he wants players took it on but
that was that was I think we as a
intellectual level
you've got to be able to adapt you've
got to be able to do what is necessary I
think to win a game not does go hell
forever
but they they were adapting were they
not to this uh peculiar Lord's Wicket
which seemed to be to paced um and so
the bounce was inconsistent do you think
do you think this means we'll have much
more short bowling in in the remaining
three tests or do you think it was just
because of that Lord
well I think I've been gone a little bit
you'll get if your vet I mean you feel
you get three or four men back on the
Lakeside boundary and you you build
short all the time and you've got people
that there's basketball frame
um I mean they're getting no good look
at that you made 98. he was within an
angel too of getting two ashes hundreds
in the same desperate
he said they
um he gets that he had no regrets
whatever when he got out from 98 and
missed his first set his entry in the
first inning yet he dragged himself off
the ground the central character are
they in the nature
didn't he I mean
he fell between his legs it was it was
it was Daryl duck itself I mean he
played magnificent guys all in both
Vinnie but surely being such a good
player he must be able to say to him so
look this is lunacy to do this because
all this can get me by it but the ball
when it's above my head I can't and my
wrists ever to give it down all I can do
is intersex all get out and you'll get
by the
Lords of nature all law of all so you're
gonna get out sooner probably rather
than later and I think it it it's
um this is batsman showing Blind Faith
in what McCullum the steps are telling
them to do that I think we get good
trigger doesn't want to be able to do
that I mean another thing that would
rather appalled me was Joe root in that
buzz dummies when he was caught behind
he skied an opal was reprieved when he
was halfway about the million and they
did the same day five minutes later at
the housing was the best batsman who was
the best bathroom in the world remember
who was completely blind by all is he I
mean by all the Dogma that is
surrounding basketball I mean I think
that was wonderful but is it wonderful
against Australia there's another point
you talk about the entertainment value
series provides iron damage on its own
without any assistance from passports
yes
if you if you play Australia you want to
beat them and with that always been the
case of Australia playing England they
want to beat them and I mean we've seen
the value of the Ashley's Series in
terms of spectator reveal and I believe
we'd have had four houses quite honest
whether it's or we'll know about all I
think it is the ashes serious
well let's let's get away from
basketball and talk about just the
Australian Pace attack
uh because I think it's fair to say
they've that that pace attack probably
has won both test matches for them
because they're just very very good are
they not
well they are not really very good
they're five miles left in the England
boaters and playing games
it's very much easier I'm playing it at
87 88 89.
that's where the Australians are and I
think we desperately need some a little
bit quick out of wood I would have
thought must come back and my other
great great oh this guy offers another
time uh they're heading I don't know
whether it will happen or all this I
very much Start vocal play with this
show right
and this is a great option bringing
folks who is a proper a really classy
weed giver and the Ambassador did
adequately but in the first things in
the second Innings really
I mean look it's very unlikely we're
going to win three test matches
but it is possible Australia did that
slides do that in 36 something Gabby
Island side in Australia won the first
two tests and then Australia won but the
last three uh and if england got up and
won as heading in it was 2-1 or two to
go Anything could happen and it would be
very very exciting so that
they probably must do that but they must
I think give the gloves to folks and but
you did say that the last one you think
England uh will still win this series
it's obviously got a lot more difficult
you have suggested you think it's
possible there but I'm going to ask you
for a firm prediction that you think the
England three Australia two by the end
of the series
well I mean it would be wonderful I
think I think that's a bit
because I mean the English thing as well
it's going to blip out some stages
somebody hasn't so far really no I mean
it might have played a part in the first
day at Lords because I thought we won
the class in in our bowling more I
thought we met
but mind you another thing which we
haven't had time to discuss now that was
hanging over it all day before we had
this uh report on the stage of English
Cricket which is the report as it said
has said really that English Greek it is
it it's not far from being assessment
and I just wonder what effect that had
on people in the restroom at the start
of the Test match Yes actually let's
talk about that if you've got time
because uh it was
um it was badly timed uh Ben Stokes came
out and said we need to do better and
there was a lot of but it did suck up a
lot of the conversation around the Test
match of the at a bad moment and so did
the uh pitch Invasion uh by the just
stop oil protesters
um on a morning when we were expected to
take wickets it might be fair to say the
England players Minds were elsewhere
yeah I know I thought I deserve the
medal for dealing with dealing with the
protesters I will never spend people hey
Gary the job off I mean I I don't know
anyway I I don't want to get involved
but but
um no I mean I mean the whole business
of this report
um there are two things that worry me
actually and I've got to be like out
what I say no uh the first thing about
it that worries me is I played Long
Creek in my life and I never made so
what this Sunday match as apparently
seen at in his day I didn't see that at
all and you may then say okay you're
privileged on a white supremacist and
all the rest and I suppose there's one
way about it if I do that but but but
there is one thing that I I would like
to know a little bit more about which is
the credentials and the instructions of
these people led by Cindy bets who made
this report she herself is an activist
in in in Black lives matter and the
report was commissioned by Ian watmore
who was challenged ECB for a very short
and it was commissioned in the immediate
as an immediate
like uh to Aziz all the problems with
Yorkshire when those were first brought
slurry and I wonder I don't know what
the composition of the committee or
went through English cricket and
produced a 300 report saying what they
did but I mean were they of the
persuasion when they were like say that
I'm not I'm not pointing your finger out
but I just
it's a little bit strange to me I watch
quite a lot of Club drinking in fact I
was watching a game until grade
yesterday and you I don't ignore his
business of racism sexism and elitism by
Sergeant is all arrested it just it just
wasn't there I mean
um
and I I just think the whole thing is it
needs a little more sharp but definition
who these people are come up with this
and and exactly I'd like to know what
that instructs were and I'd like to know
who they were uh I'm not saying I
necessarily
are they people who are likely to beside
me every exaggerating well I don't know
but I'll just see where I'm coming from
I see I see entirely where you come from
and I think the report read to me as
though it was on a mission to find
English Cricket to be racist and it
succeeded in doing that
uh and uh and and again it's a shame
because well I mean my my sons played
Cricket uh locally and there's
absolutely no
um lack of diversity in the cricket
there but boys versus girls of all
different races and so on
um and I think there is this mood for
self-fragilation
um and it's particularly can I tell you
one thing I learned yesterday
um if I again I'll ask you a question I
want you to answer it I mean
uh this year the MCC committee wanted to
cancel Leighton Harry match the ultimate
garage
as they lead this game they are
historically the two earliest games
there and the 89 busy now match played
in 1805 on the original Lord's Prayer
now is and it's the only surviving
connection uh and I we got it reprieved
for a total of six of six years now this
year they had a wonderful game
four runs and again side wins by four
runs is a trial it's a great game now
when I say when I said to you how many
people
um how many people of color you think
would have been playing in that match
what would you say
uh I would say probably a fair few maybe
sort of 40 percent
well in which case are you all right the
word then in which case you've done
really well and that is right most
people I have said it's on two three
four but I mean I think I mean I think
the Apple there is and a lot of people
again
it is everything and yet it is a great
deal more diverse I think oh there's
more diversity there than a lot of
people will think yes well Henry on that
uh semi-controversial league but I don't
think it should be controversial at all
to say it uh we will end it there but
please come back after the next test and
uh let's hope England have got one back
[Music]
thank you